today's video is brought to you
by crossout more on them in a bit
so welcome back to our biographic series on
pompeii the great one of the most significant
figures in the history of ancient rome his career
was so prolific that we just had to give it the
super-sized treatment this is part two of a
two-parter do make sure you check out the first
part if you haven't seen it yet because otherwise
this one's not gonna make a lot of sense is it
the last time we saw our intrepid hero he
had just won the sartorian war this alone
was worthy of another military triumph back in
rome but pompe was not the kind of guy to just
sit back and take it easy when it was fighting
to be had during the years that pompeii had been
away in hispania a slave rebellion had erupted
in italy in 73 bc started by a few dozen escaped
gladiators from a training school a capua led
by a dude named spartacus at first this was of
no particular concern after all slave uprisings
happened all the time and we usually crush quickly
mercilessly this one however was different
before long the gladiators were joined by tens
of thousands of other warriors as they led raids
all over italy the senate solution was to send a
praetor named glaber after them with a force of
poorly trained poorly equipped militia thinking
that it would do the trick in fact it did not
do the trick it fumbled the trick worse than a
drunk magician on one dollar beer night glib's
militia was annihilated by spartacus's forces and
then another prey tour sent on a second expedition
suffered the exact same fate if anything they were
helping the gladiator's cause because his men
equipped themselves with the weapons and armor
of the dead romans while word spread of the mighty
spartacus and made even more people join him the
following year rome sent two consular legions
after the slaves no more militia this time around
these were proper roman soldiers and yet the same
thing happened by 71 bc the senate realized they
were in a spot of bother by dismissing the revolt
in its early stages they allowed it to grow to
dangerous levels some estimated that spartacus's
army may have exceeded a hundred thousand men
and they could be thinking about marching on rome
itself this was the time when pompeii would have
come in handy but he was still in espana at this
point therefore the senate turned to their second
best option marcus crassus pompeo and crassus
had fought together under sula and enjoyed a
frenemy relationship they often had to compete
for the same goals but overall they both benefited
more from having the other one around than getting
rid of them crassus accepted the task of ridding
rome of spartacus and his slave army and this time
there were no half-measures crassus went after his
target with eight legions of roman soldiers plus
tens of thousands of auxiliaries crassus gained
the upper hand in the conflict and at one point
had trapped spartacus and his army in brutium and
launched a war of attrition hoping to starve them
out things were going well until crassus received
terrible news he was getting reinforcements
but hold on a minute wouldn't that be good news
well no not really because the reinforcements
consisted of pompeii and his army he had finished
his work in espana just in time to take part in
the dale end of the gladiator war and collect
his share of the credit unsurprisingly crassus
wanted the glory for himself but on the other side
spartacus wasn't thrilled with the idea either
since it meant fighting two armies instead of one
therefore the two camps met in combat once and for
all at the battle of solarius river crassus was
triumphant and spartacus presumably was killed
in battle since his body was never recovered
and yet it was pompeii who had the last laugh a
few thousand slaves managed to slip past crassus
forces and they walked right into bombay's army
which was just arriving to join in the fray after
he diligently slaughtered every last one of them
pompey sent word to the senate saying that krasus
had conquered the gladiators in pitched battle but
that he himself had extrapolated the war entirely
this was technically correct which is the best
kind of correct but he was clearly exaggerating
his role in the matter while minimizing that
of crassus the latter had no choice but to just
green and bear it he knew that pompeii was more
popular than him and he didn't want to come off as
bitter and complaining therefore when they arrived
in rome crassus just sat back and watched the city
throw another triumph in pompeii's honor although
truth be told it was mainly for his actions in the
satorian war and not the slave rebellion once
it was over crassus approached pompeii with a
smile on his face and an extended handshake
and made clear his true intentions he wanted
his support for the position of consul and pompeii
was happy to give it to him in fact both men were
put forward as candidates for the console ship
the following year technically pompeii should
not have been eligible both due to his young age
and because he had never held any of the lesser
officers but the entire curse of sonorum went out
the window when it came to pompeii ultimately a
special decree was passed and in 70 bc both men
were elected consoles the most significant thing
that pompey did during his time as consul
was to bring back the plebeian tribune or
the tribune of the people historically this was
the first office in rome open to commoners and
it was also their greatest check on the power
of the upper classes since the tribune could
veto the decisions of the senate and even the
consuls sulla did away with the position but both
pompei and crassus agreed to restore it to the
tremendous pleasure of the roman people apparently
it was the only act during their one year term
which the two powerful consuls cooperated on
once pompey's consulship was over he was ready to
put down the pen and pick up the sword again he
was still in his prime after all so there was no
reason for him to give up the military life that
he loved so much surely rome was always embroiled
in one conflict or another and now was no
exception as the republic was fighting the third
mithridatic war against mithridates vi the king
of pontus nowadays mithridates isn't particularly
well known which is a bit unfair since he was one
of rome's most formidable opponents during its
republic years he had been a thorn in their side
for decades and had waged his first war with rome
against sulla back then sulla had the upper hand
and could have probably eradicated the problem
completely however he was rushing to get back
to rome to deal with that pesky civil war so he
hastily agreed to a treaty with mithridates then
in 83 bc the second war started but this one was
relatively brief and proved inconclusive before
each side retreated deep into its own territory
again that's how we arrived at the third and final
mithridatic war the longest of the bunch it
started in 74 bc when mithridates invaded the
neighboring kingdom of bithenia this was intended
to become a roman province but if you're good at
remembering dates you might recall that at that
time pompeii was in hispania fighting the satorian
war so he couldn't also go to anatolia to fight
the kingdom of pontus therefore the two consuls
of that year lucius lysinius lucillus and marcus
aurelius cotter were sent to deal with the problem
and they did a pretty good job they defeated
mithridates and pushed him back several times
but they couldn't deal with the threat permanently
by 69 bc the war was still going hot and pompeii
was raring to go but there was just one problem
there were no vacancies mithridates was one of the
republic's greatest enemies and taking him down
would have been a major feather in the cap or you
know laurel reef of a military commander the guy
could pull that off well he knew he was going to
get a biographics video 2000 years later and so
did every other roman general nobody was willing
to give up their spot in the war for pompeii but
that was okay because he had another foe to fight
pirates over the last couple of decades pirates
in the mediterranean had become an ever-increasing
problem for rome they were responsible for attacks
on vital grain ships as well as taking prominent
romans prisoner and holding them for ransom
the most famous example was julius caesar who
was captured in 75 bc and held captive for over
a month like spartacus and his gladiators the
pirates started out as a minor nuisance because
of this rome assumed it could deal with them at
any time so it left them unchecked until they
became a serious threat plutarch estimated that
at the height of their power the pirates had over
1 000 ships and controlled 400 cities several
roman commanders tried to subdue the marauders and
failed and in 67 bc one fleet of pirates got so
cocky that they sailed up the mouth of the tiber
and attacked the port austere near rome itself
such an act was considered a great humiliation for
the republic that couldn't even protect the waters
near its capital therefore an extraordinary move
was made a new law was passed alex gabinia which
conferred great powers on a pro-consul and gave
him always complete control over the port cities
in the mediterranean sea this was accompanied
by significant financial resources and a large
fleet in order to deal with the pirates and
the man who gained these remarkable privileges
was none other than pompeii not everyone
was thrilled with the decision and many
fought fervently to stop the law from passing they
were uncomfortable with the idea of one person
having all of that authority and to be fair they
had a point just in the last 20 years or so there
have been several men who rebelled against rome's
status quo and tried to take power for themselves
fortunately for the senate pompeii was not one
such man sure he wanted all the power the money
and glory that he could get but he was content
with doing it within the bounds established by
the roman republic in terms of pure efficiency
this might have been pompe's finest hour
he had 200 ships at his disposal and as many
soldiers as he needed he divided the mediterranean
into 13 districts and each one was assigned a
number of ships led by a commander he trusted
meanwhile pompei himself traveled with his 60 best
ships to cilicia on the southern coast of anatolia
since that was the biggest pirate haven within 40
days most of the seas were free of pirates pompeii
showed great mercy to those he captured which
prompted many others to surrender willingly since
they knew the good times were over pompeii then
needed just a few more months to track down the
ones who refused to submit peacefully overall it
was a great success for pompei and it was followed
by even more good news because the senate was
starting to think that maybe he should deal with
mithridates after all now just before we continue
with today's video let me take a moment to tell
you about the sponsor of this episode crossout
what is crossout well it's a vehicle shooter
game as in you drive a tank like creation around
and you try to blow up other people's tank-like
creations but it goes beyond that because all
of the vehicles are made by the players and this
isn't somewhere select from 20 options and change
the paint sort of thing you can really customize
it however you want to build your vehicle from the
ground up indeed i built mine so badly initially
that they were like it's got too many guns and
off batteries it just isn't gonna work but you
get the hang of it pretty quickly and then you
go to battle and in battle you'll see some truly
wacky creations from other players throw on a
chainsaw if you want but there's also plasma
weapons like tons and tons of options there's
also different game modes so for me i like to
jump in for a quick battle 10 minute break from
work it's nice but there's also longer battles you
can play as well as racing battle royale fights
and much more so look crossout is free it's a lot
of fun and if you use my link below you'll get
an exclusive bonus as well as a choice between
three weapons you'll get unique pixel plane as
well as a choice between three weapons as well
as a powerful vehicle cabin like i say link below
it's free why not and now back to today's video
it was in early 66 bc that a tribune named
manilius began suggesting that rome turned
over its eastern command to pompeii as we said
the previous guy locules was doing all right
but he suffered a major setback in 67 bc when he
lost an important battle that turned the tide to
mithridates favor some were even accusing lucillus
of prolonging the war intentionally so that he
could loot and plunder as much as possible a
new law was passed laxmanilia which made it
official pompeii was now in charge apparently
when he heard of his new appointment pompey
reacted with mock histrionics bemoaning the fact
that he's always the one who has to take on these
massive challenges he said alas for my endless
tasks how much better it were to be an unknown man
if i am never to cease from my military service
and cannot lay aside this load of envy and spend
my time in the country with my wife this was all
for show of course any close friend of pompeii
understood that this was basically his dream job
and certainly pompeii wasted no time in raising an
army and marching east towards anatolia he stopped
at every kingdom and province along the way not
only to continue building his forces but also
to undo everything la solas had done he rewarded
those that lacillus had punished and punished
those that he had favored if nothing else it was
just to show everyone that lucille's was now as
weak as a newborn lamb and that pompeii was the
new head honcho there wasn't much losulus could
do about it but he did insult pompei by comparing
him to a lazy carrion bird who feasted on the
bodies that others had killed referring here to
the fact that he always joined wars towards the
end after other men such as crassus metallus and
catalysts had done the work it's an interesting
idea and it might be a valid criticism it's also
what definitely happened in this case by the time
pompe made his appearance in 65 bc the kingdom
of pontus was mainly under roman control
and the fighting always taking place
in its neighboring allied kingdoms such as armenia
cultures and iberia pompeii started his campaign
by fighting mithridates at the battle of lysis
in ionia it was a decisive victory for pompeii
and he forced his opponent to fall back and
retreat it to the mountains mithradartes was
hoping that his allies would keep pompeii busy
while he raised a new army but he was wrong on
both counts his allies proved no match for the
roman might a few more battles occurred in 65 bc
all won by pompeii and victory at the battle
of abbas against the kingdom of albania
turned out to be the last open engagement of
the campaign meanwhile mithridates was not
successful in reinforcing his army it seems that
the local forces have been all but exhausted and
those who remained were fed up with years
and years of war even the king's own sons
rebelled against their father so with no other
prospects mithridates vi committed suicide in
63 bc half of the kingdom of pontus was annexed
by rome and together with bethenia it was turned
into a new roman province pompeii had won the
mithridatic war but he wasn't finished since he
was already in the area and still had an army
itching for a fight why not put it to good use
he captured syria turning it into another roman
province he also attacked judea annexing half of
it and rendering the other half into a powerless
vassal state he then liberated hundreds of small
towns settlements and strongholds and completely
reorganized rome's eastern defensive frontier into
a new system that stayed in place for hundreds
of years pompeii had no authority to do any of
this by the way officially his reasoning was
that the region was unstable and that this was
a threat to rome's new eastern possessions but
many feared that he had completely given in to
his insatiable lust for power and glory
and that soon after rome would be next
the entire senate collectively breathed a sigh
of relief in december 62 bc when they found out
that pompeii had reached brundicium in southern
italy and had disbanded his army he paid his
soldiers sent them on their merry way and went
off on a sort of celebration tour throughout
italy suffice to say that he expected another
triumph when he reached rome his actions against
the pirates and against mithridates were more
than enough to warrant such festivities but this
was the biggest triumph in the history of rome
cassia's d.o referred to it as the great event and
said that pompeii had a trophy for every single
war he won and then a giant one quote decked out
in costly fashion and bearing an inscription
stating that it was a trophy of the inhabited
world plutarch gave a more detailed account
that truly highlighted the extent of pompei's
conquests he said his triumph had such a magnitude
that although it was distributed over two days
still the time would not suffice inscriptions born
in advance of a procession integrated the nations
over which he triumphed these were pontus armenia
cappadocia falgonia media culture siberia albania
syria cilicia mesopotamia phoenicia and palestine
judea arabia and all the power of the pirates
among these people no less than a thousand
strongholds have been captured in cities not
much under 900 in number beside 800 piratical
ships while 39 cities have been founded to put
it simply rome had never seen a champion the
likes of pompey the great in spite of this
or more likely because of this pompeii
didn't wield a lot of political influence
he wanted the senate to ratify and recognize
all the city's vassal states and kings that he
installed in the east but they were reluctant to
do so many senators had been wary for years of all
the power granted to pompeii so they thought it
best to cut him down to size a little bit there
wasn't much pompe could do about it he was at home
on the battlefield not in the senate house he knew
he didn't have the political muscle to take on its
detractors but that would soon change around 60 bc
a powerful alliance was formed the first tromboras
an informal coalition between three of rome's
wealthiest most influential and most popular
figures pompeii marcus crassus and julius caesar
the goal was for each one to support the interests
of the other two but it's pretty clear that caesar
got the most out of their little on taunt first
he was given the consulship in 59 bc then he was
made a governor and finally he was sent to fight
in the gallic wars on his end the trauma enabled
pompeii to get his eastern settlements ratified
and land grants provided for his veterans he was
also appointed consul again in 55 bc and enjoyed
a five-year stint as prefectus anony a important
position that placed him in charge of the grain
supply to rome despite its effectiveness from the
beginning the alliance was tenuous at best pompei
and crassus never truly liked each other pompe and
caesar grew closer when the former married the
latter's daughter julia however she died during
childbirth in 54 bc and the relationship between
pompei and caesar turned decidedly frostier from
then on the following year the trumbet officially
ended after crassus died at the battle of carhei
against the parthian empire and then a war
erupted that changed the course of history forever
look we're not going to go into a massive preamble
about the start of the civil war that has more to
do with caesar than it does to do with pompeii
and we already have a bio on julius caesar if
you want that story in full suffice to say that in
49 bc caesar crossed the rubicon after winning the
gaelic wars he refused a demand from the senate
to disband his troops and marched into italy
with an army from that point on civil war became
inevitable all those years the senate feared that
this was something that pompey would do although
he never did and now that caesar had done it
they rushed to pompei for help he agreed but
was caught off guard by the rapid pace at which
caesar advanced toward rome when the two sides
first met in battle at the siege of brundicium
an outmanned and ill-prepared pompei suffered
one of his greatest defeats this gave pompei the
dark realization that he could not defend rome
so he abandoned the city and fled to macedonia
to properly mobilize his forces he set up his
camp in the city of diraccia in modern-day albania
caesar besieged the city in 48 bc but after months
of inconclusive skirmishes he conceded defeat and
made a strategic retreat thus tying their score
at one all the great decider occurred in august
of that year at the battle of fasalas in central
greece pompei didn't want to do it he thought
he was rushing things but his allies all pressured
him to meet up with a confederate named metallia
scepio and take out caesar but that's not how
things went down pompeii's plan was to make use
of his large cavalry attack caesar's right wing
from the flank go around the rear of the enemy and
trap them between two armies however caesar
shrewdly guessed pompey's strategy and reinforced
his right wing but kept his extra soldiers out
of sight until it was too late for pompeii's men
they pounced at the right time and brought chaos
confusion and death to pompei's cavalry units
they retreated in a panic and from that moment on
the battle was as good as lost it was undoubtedly
pompe's greatest defeat he escaped the battlefield
disguised as a civilian and fled to egypt thinking
that the ptolemies were friendly and would help
him rebuild his army but they had already chosen
their side on september 28 48 bc just one day
short of his 58th birthday pompey disembarked
at alexandria and was immediately waylaid by
assassins who stabbed him to death right on the
dock they cut up his head and threw his body in
the ocean a freed man loyal to pompeii fished out
his corpse and gave him a modest funeral caesar
himself was appalled by this act and burst into
tears when he was presented with pompeii's head
and seal ring he demanded pompe's assassins and
had them put to death and that was the anonymous
end of one of history's greatest military careers